If you want to hear about how Mordeo, the
Crypt monster series we talked about last
week on Things You Missed, could tie into
Shelley, the Crypt monster series I’m gonna
talk about today, then stick around to the
end of this video.
Today’s video was made possible by our sponsor
Crypt TV.
The first episode of Season 2 of Shelley has
just come out and as with all of Crypt’s
2019 productions it’s all part of a greater
universe.
There are little clues hidden throughout,
about how this all fits in with the grand
story that each of these series make up.
But before we get into my theory about how
Shelley Season 2 fits into this universe,
let’s take a quick look back at Season 1.
Season 1 takes place 20 years after the 1998
graduation at Avon Manor High School, where
an introverted floor hockey athlete hangs
by the neck at the graduation ceremony.
The story follows Nicks, Lauren and Heidi,
three bullies who picked on Shelley and other
girls back in the day.
At the reunion, Heidi fires an insult at a
girl names Celine, by bringing up her old
nickname Blobby.
Lauren excuses herself to go to the bathroom,
where she has a flashback of them bullying
Shelley, calling her Silent Shelley, and tightening
her tie around her neck.
“Can you talk now?
Huh?”
Uhh, no probably not.
You’re kind of blocking her wind-pipe thing.
Lauren is attacked by a monster resembling
Shelley.
When Nicks and Heidi go looking for her, after
discovering an old photo of when Shelley was
just a Lv 1 crook, they find Lauren’s jaw
has been removed, possibly intended as a literal
silencing in response to their “Silent Shelley”
taunts.
A tie is also tightened around her neck.
They see this as a sign that someone knows
their secret, but that secret is not yet revealed.
In the next scene, Heidi and Nicks run into
the locker room.
Here’s a little free tip for you.
If the ghost of student athlete is haunting
you, don’t go in the locker room, literally
go anywhere else.
Nicks gets picked off with a mean slapshot,
leaving just Heidi remaining.
Throughout the school there are posters advertising
a production of MacBeth.
This is a fitting reference, because MacBeth
is a Shakespeare character who becomes riddled
with guilt after committing a murder.
We soon find that this is the case with the
bullies as well.
That little neck tie incident actually killed
Shelley or at least incapacitated her, so
the girls make it look like a suicide, and
almost get away with it if not for Celine,
aka Blobby, catching them in the act.
The pursuer reveals herself to be none other
than Celine and Heidi is chased into what
appears to be that MacBeth production.
She almost gets away, but there’s a second
killer, the real Shelley, who finally gets
her revenge.
Hand in hand, we see that Celine and Shelley
have matching bracelets and there’s a little
post-credits scene hinting that in Season
2, Shelley is going to target the school’s
staff.
That’s where this theory takes off, with
this symbol in the school administration’s
office.
It appears to be a ripped out page of the
book, The Crypt Tome, which is a manual for
men to turn themselves into monsters that
appears in several Crypt series'.
This symbol in particular is the emblem seen
on the Door in the Woods, a Crypt Monster
Universe short film about a colony sworn to
protect the world from a monster known as
The Brute.
The Brute is basically a level 50 boss.
The symbol is seen on the door and on the
clothing of everyone in the colony.
My theory is that the schools in Shelley are
built on the ground upon which this colony
once resided.
That’s right, I said schools, plural.
It seems that Shelley’s school, Avon Manor,
is an all-girls school located next to the
all-boys school.
The headmaster of Avon Manor even says that
there are multiple schools when she talks
on the phone with Hargate, who is presumably
in charge of the boys’ school.
“Our schools are being disgraced.”
On top of that, in this shot of Hargate’s
office, there is a picture of the boys’
school’s crest, which is different than
the Avon Manor crest.
The symbol of Avon Manor is a fox, but this
school seems to have a stag -- which interestingly
enough, is the animal head of Mordeo.
This is a pretty small detail, and it remains
to be seen if there will really be any crossover,
but it’s definitely something to keep an
eye on.
But there’s definitely a connection with
The Door In Woods, and I believe it has something
to do with the bracelet that Shelly recovers
from Celine, which is seen to been originally
given to her by this guy, who I would assume
is Shelley’s boyfriend from the boy’s
school.
The bracelet is seen at the end of the episode
giving life to this buried person.
Maybe this is the reason that Brute and Shelley
are seemingly invincible.
This revival ritual, likely taken out of the
Crypt Tome, could bring its subject back to
life and give them new monstrous powers.
Shelley also has similar themes to The Door
In The Woods, with adults trying to keep this
ancient power hidden away from the kids, and
the rest of the world in both stories.
“Having people snooping around could ruin
us.”
So it would appear that after all this time,
the powers in charge of the colony are still
trying to supress the evil that lies within.
Let me know what you think of this theory
in the comments and any other thoughts you
have on Shelley, The Door In The Woods, Mordeo,
and anything else that could be connected
to this storyline.
Of course you’ll want to stay tuned to this
entire season of Shelley.
Remember to subscribe to Crypt TV for new
Crypt Monster Universe videos every Friday,
ring the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
Or get brought back.